rush limbaugh passes away and the online
left celebrates the biden administration
has literally no idea what the hell it's
talking about when it comes to reopening
schools
and we learn from the washington post
that if you spray gorilla glue in your
hair it's because of systemic racism i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
speaking of which
you may have noticed the big tech bros
not your friends those are people who
want to restrict your access to
information
and also monetize your data at the exact
same time why would you give
your data to these folks instead protect
your data the way that i do by using
expressvpn
everything you search for watch or click
online can be tracked by big tech
companies they can then match your
activity to your true identity
using your device's unique ip address
well when i switch on expressvpn with my
computer or phone my ip address is
masked by a secure vpn server that makes
it harder for websites to identify me
the expressvpn app also encrypts my
network data to protect my sensitive
information from being compromised plus
you can use expressvpn on up to five
devices simultaneously so multiple users
on your network can stay safe with a
single subscription what i like most is
how easy it is to use it takes just one
click to protect all your devices which
is why they are rated the number one vpn
by cnet and wired so stop handing over
your data to big tech companies go with
the vpn i trust for online protection
visit expressvpn.com to get three months
free
on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn dot com slash band to
get three extra months for free go to
expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more okay well
big news of the day yesterday and
honestly historic news the death of rush
limbaugh
so for those of you who never listened
to russia missed out rush was
the granddaddy not only of talk radio
but of all the alternative media without
rush limbaugh there is no alternative
media
you have to understand what rush was and
what he was not
so what he was not is what the media are
calling him today a bigot
a vicious terrible person saying the
world is better off
because he is dead this is stuff that
you are seeing in mainstream media
outlets
it's stuff that you're seeing certainly
on twitter which allowed rot in hell to
trend
when rush limbaugh died as well as rest
in piss
you can tell that the left really didn't
like this guy here's the thing the
reason they didn't like rush
is because they kept trying to cancel
him and they kept failing the reason
they didn't like rush is because
rush provided an alternative until there
was rush there was a media monopoly in
this country on the left
rush was the first point of push back to
that now there have been conservatives
who've been
on mainstream television before milton
friedman's free to choose aired on pbs
and william f buckley's firing line was
also on pbs but
that was basically conservatives
existing at the suffrance of liberal
liberal overlords in the media the
reality is that
at the very beginning there were just
three networks abc nbc cbs all of them
leaned to the left
virtually every major newspaper in the
united states leaned to the left
and when it came to radio radio was
basically a dead medium certainly the am
band was a dead medium
it was really hard to listen to the
quality was really staticky
it was a bad place for music right all
of the music had
migrated over to fm so am radio was
basically dead
and the fairness doctrine rule the
fairness doctrine was this
unconstitutional i think doctrine
that suggested that if you had a
broadcast license you had to
be fair in your presentation of the
issues which was a completely subjective
interpretation because there was no way
that folks with broadcast licenses were
being fair
in their presentation of the issues they
certainly were not providing all sides
of any particular issue
well in 1987 the fcc under ronald reagan
got rid of the fairness doctrine
and in doing so they opened the path to
am radio because they allowed people
with broadcast licenses
to stop worrying about government
mastering them and start worrying about
what the market wanted to hear
in 1989 rush limbaugh launches the rush
limbaugh show
and it immediately becomes a sensation
and it becomes a sensation because
there's an entire side of the political
aisle that for decades
has had no daily outlet for the news
remember there's no major mainstream
newspaper that was right-wing
there was no television state fox news
did not exist and none of this
infrastructure existed
and when it came to daily news there was
no internet so that meant that all the
news that you ever got
was daily news from the left and even
those shows that i mentioned before
a special like milton friedman that
happened once in a blue moon and william
f buckley that might happen
once a week but it certainly wasn't
every day it certainly wasn't to
commentary on the narrative
as it was being spun out by the left in
real time so rush comes along
and rush is maybe the most talented
person ever to enter the radio medium i
mean probably without question he's the
most talented person
ever to enter the radio medium he
single-handedly makes the am
band a thing because suddenly here is a
person who is funny this is what drives
the left absolutely up a wall is the
fact that rush was a funny person
rush was entertaining and rush saw
himself as an entertainer he called
himself a lovable little fuzzball he
talked about i was going to fight the
left
with one half of his brains hide behind
his back talents on loan from god and
all this is all tongue-in-cheek kind of
stuff
and rush approached the issues with
humor and this made him
entertaining and subversive and the left
could not handle it and if you talk to
any conservative born after 1960 rush
was a seminal figure in their life
people of my age range we listened to
rush because my dad was listening to
rush in the car
and on the way to ucla when he was
driving me to ucla some days
it would be rush limbaugh on in the car
and then when i was driving myself in my
1986 honda civic with no air conditioner
it was listening to rush
on my way in the car and rush was
defiant
in his resistance of liberal narratives
rush was willing to say things that were
true
but that might not please the people on
the left
and this gave a lot of people courage
you gave me courage when i was in class
it gave me weapons to argue my position
when i was at ucla now left today will
tell you that russia was a polarizing
figure super oppositional super terrible
here's the reality
the left had a monopoly anybody who
breaks a monopoly is seen by the
monopolists as defiant and oppositional
that's the way this works everybody on
the right right now who refuses to
kowtow to the woke
authoritarian left line is seen as
oppositional and polarizing and defiant
it doesn't matter that people like me do
the sunday special
every week and many weeks it is people
on the left that does not matter
none of that really makes a difference
the idea is that anybody who speaks up
against the left is the cause of the
polarization because the left should
have complete dominance
rush was the first person to deny this
rush was the first person to say listen
i exist you exist i hear you and you
hear me
and we can communicate with each other
you the conservative living in the
middle of the country who's been
completely overlooked by the
establishment media
you have a voice and you have a place
you can go
to hear people who agree with you and
you have arguments that you can leverage
in support of your viewpoint this is why
the left was so frightened of rush
limbaugh because rush
was entertaining because rush did have a
big crowd it's why the left decided they
were going to go after him
i think it is fair to say that if it
were not for rush there would not be
this entire left-wing apparatus designed
at destroying people in rightwing media
because there wouldn't be a right-wing
media
fox news would not exist without rush
limbaugh rush limbaugh was the test case
he was the canary in the coal mine
for the suggestion that there was in
fact a massive market for conservative
content
in the united states because again the
methods of dissemination just didn't
exist
to that point so rush was a
deeply important figure in the history
of conservatism he also had a gift
for distilling down complex arguments to
something more simple
and william f buckley was famously
sesquipedalian right he would use words
that nobody knew
he was extraordinarily literate but this
didn't exactly
make him always the best expositor of
conservative to the truck driver
to the guy who didn't go to college rush
was the guy who talked to everyone
russia never talked down to anyone and
listen i'm a huge buckley fan but there
is no question that
buckley's chief audience was college
graduates people who read national
review are not the same people who
listen to talk radio
rush was the person who brought
conservatism to the common man which is
why you saw in 1994
after newt gingrich became speaker of
the house rush was given an honorary
congressional seat by
members of the of the republican party
in congress
you know russia's willingness and
ability to explain conservative
viewpoints made him unique in the space
and also made him the target of unique
ire from the left
very early on the left identified him as
a threat and then they dedicated nearly
everything in their arsenal to
destroying him a lot of the same stuff
that you see today started with rush
the attempts to de-platform he attempts
to go after his advertisers all that
started with rush
the attempt to blame people on the right
for violence with which they had nothing
to do
that all started with rush i'm old
enough to remember when the left tried
to blame rush for the oklahoma city
bombing
so rush was just the first guy there and
not only the first guy there the most
talented guy there
and you can sense how important rush was
by the amount that the left hates him
despises him i mean after after he died
again the reaction from the left which
is sometimes muted depending on who dies
was absolutely unbridled
absolutely unbridled and to pretend by
the way that this exists equally on both
sides of the aisle is is very silly
when ruth bader ginsburg died there
weren't people on the right who were
talking about
what a terrible evil person she was in
the world is better off without her
because
it wasn't true but with the left the
idea is that rush limbaugh was the font
head of all evil
especially because of course donald
trump had just been elected presidents
of the united states and you've been
president of the united states and
russia been a big trump supporter
but for those of us who listened to rush
for 30 years long before trump
was ever even in the rearview mirror we
recognized that trust
we recognized that russia's legacy was
way more than that it was giving people
a voice it was making people feel heard
and more importantly he was beginning a
mass movement in favor of conservatism
that actually had alternative outlets
daily wire would not exist where not for
rush limbaugh this podcast would not
exist where not for rush limbaugh
certainly this radio show would not
exist
were it not for rush limbaugh rush built
this right we're all sort of living
in the house that rush built in a second
we're going to talk a little bit more
about rush limbaugh and we'll talk about
the blowback that he's receiving after
his death
yeah if if you can be judged by your
friends then you can be certainly judged
by the people who are really pissed off
at you even after you die
and that is certainly the case with rush
limbaugh we'll get some more of this in
just one second first
let us talk about something that you
need to do as a responsible human being
that of course is you should have life
insurance
because let's be real about this all of
us have an expiration date and when that
happens we want to make sure our
families are taken care of
you need more cash to put toward the
things that you care about so why would
you spend too much on life insurance
instead why not check out policy genius
policy genius can help you compare life
insurance rates and say 50
or more in the process first you head on
over to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as a bucket a you
might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process they'll
take care of everything for you that
kind of service has earned policy genius
a five-star rating
across over 1 600 reviews on trustpilot
and google
if you're worried that march is just
around the corner and you've barely
gotten anything done take a deep breath
policy genius will help you make the
most of this short month in minutes
you could say 50 or more by comparing
quotes feel good knowing your loved ones
would be taken care of if god forbid
anything were to happen to you go to
policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important
to get it right okay so rush limbaugh's
wife katherine made an announcement
on his show wednesday morning she said
losing a loved one is terribly difficult
even more so when that loved one is
larger than life rush will forever be
the greatest
of all time and that of course is true
just speaking of his life rush limbaugh
got started as a morning talk show host
in 1983
at kansas city's kmbc he went to
california's kfbk in sacramento in 1986
and in 1988 he relocated to new york and
signed his syndication deal for the rush
limbaugh show
his daily show on new york's wabc aired
on 56 networks eventually grew
into the most listened to radio program
of all time it reached more than 600
stations
and an an estimated audience of some 27
million listeners according to emily's
and audi over at daily wire in 1993
limbo was inducted as a member of the
national radio hall of fame in many ways
he shaped the modern republican party he
was an early supporter of the tea
parties in
20 in 2009 and then presidential
candidate donald trump
in 2016 of course limbaugh said several
years ago we stood for the concepts that
are in our declaration of independence
right to life liberty pursuit of
happiness we stood for that we were the
beacon for it to this day that is why
the oppressed of the world still seek
to come to this country okay and
you can i mean the the reaction on the
right is
universal warning the editorial board of
the wall street journal
says a familiar voice in american media
and politics has gone quiet rush limb by
the most listened to radio host in
america for 30 years died wednesday at
age 70.
we recall how bracing the rush limbaugh
show was in its early days for decades
the airways
had been governed by the fairness
doctrine a federal regulation requiring
stations to balance quote-unquote
controversial claims with contrasting
viewpoints
the rule gave incumbent candidates and
mainstream news outlets in your monopoly
on public discourse
reagan scrapped the fairness doctrine in
1987 by the 1992 presidential campaign
the radio star's first name was known
across the united states
he was invaluable to the conservative
movement of the 90s he would spend an
hour explaining supply-side tax policy
or making the case for deregulation
millions of americans had never heard a
coherent argument against the welfare
state or roe vs wade until they tuned in
to limbaugh's show
he played an enormous role in
popularizing conservative ideas and
policies
his critics called him a racist and
about everything else which was always
unfair his real offense was to gain
millions of weekly listeners by mocking
the left's pieties he dissected
environmental scare campaigns he
ridiculed the news media for finding
epidemics of homelessness only during
republican administrations
in 1994 bill clinton called the st louis
radio station from air force one
to complain about limbaugh's criticism
not for the last time blaming scrappy
radio
host for his own political woes
in recent years with the rise of more
serbian competitors and a general
souring of public discourse limbaugh
took on a more exasperated tone says the
wall street journal
he also moved to the trumpian right on
issues like trade immigration and
foreign policy but unlike others on the
talk radio right
he kept his sense of humor and rarely
let anger drown his fundamental optimism
about the united states his great
strength was never to take himself too
seriously limbaugh knew he was an
entertainer not an intellectual or
politician he said so many times
he was popular because he was superb his
craft and represented traditional
american values that the dominant
culture too often demeans and that of
course is exactly right
now naturally the left reacted to his
death
by doing exactly what they do with
people they don't like when those people
are alive they took everything that he
ever said out of context they found his
worst comments and they strung them
together
to form the corpus of his life is what
cnn did so cnn
instead of paying tribute to one of the
pioneers of an entire medium
and maybe the pioneer when it came to
the establishment of an alternative
media
of course cnn wouldn't like this because
it breaks cnn's monopoly instead
they ran an entire montage of just
limbaugh's worst low lights right
because to the left that's what
everybody is
you are just a company imagine if your
life at your at your funeral
your life for just all of your worst
moments strung together here's the thing
about rush limbaugh rush limbaugh was on
air live three hours a day for 30
years for 30 years it is impossible to
speak
for three hours a day for 30 years and
never say anything
that you don't regret right that is just
a fundamental reality of life
but for the left it's the things that
that he said that offended people or the
things that he said that he then
apologized for
that is the compendium of what rush
limbaugh stood for for his listeners in
the same way
that all of the all the worst things
about donald trump that's the stuff you
embrace because the idea here is that
rush was popular because he was bad
right that's the idea is that if you
agreed with rush on fundamental
principles
this also meant that you were in kahoot
with
the things that he regretted having said
and so cnn
upon his death they don't run a sort of
tribute to rush
as a human being instead they decide
that it's important that they run a
montage of immediate matters
essentially edited compendium of all of
his all of his
heresies fans known as ditto heads
cheered his brazen style
while critics blasted him for racist
sexist and other offensive speech
he accused actor michael j fox of
exaggerating his parkinson's symptoms
he is moving all around and shaking and
it's purely an act
and he insulted a college student who
advocated for access to birth control
a conservative media icon whose legacy
will always symbolize
division i mean that from cnn from brian
stelter
russia's legacy will always symbolize
division cnn
preceded rush cnn is maybe the most
divisive force in the american media
right now
because they pretend to be objective and
they clearly are not but this is what
they boil down all conservatives you see
it's not about what he said about sandra
fluck
and it's not about what he said about
michael j fox i'm sure he regretted both
of those i think he apologized for both
of those things
actually what it is for the left is that
if you are a conservative you
are all of the worst aspects of you if
you are conservative
then all they want you to remember is
all of that stuff right you don't have
the literally thousands of hours of rush
limbaugh talking
about deep and profound issues you don't
have any clips on cnn and rush limbaugh
at the end of his life talking
about how to die with dignity which he
did talk about on his show
instead what you get is that crap hey
this is because this is what the left
thinks of you but the left thinks of you
is that you are that
and they think rush was that rush was
not that rush was by all accounts one of
the kindest people that people had met
tammy bruce who is a uh who was a former
left-wing
radio host and ended up becoming
right-wing has a beautiful tribute to
him today eric erickson who's always
him today
i only had the pleasure of meeting
russian person once and over the phone
once i i spoke with him over the phone
actually twice i spoke with him over the
phone because i was in his limb letter
a couple of times just an absolute
gentleman very kind extraordinarily
generous
when i met him in person rush was
shockingly
retiring he was not the sort of
bombastic figure that you hear on the
air
russia was somebody who has been
described by eric erickson i think
correctly is having a quiet soul
that's who rush was people talk about
the fact that he would
give these enormous tips these five ten
thousand dollar tips at the dinner
there are people on both sides of the
aisle who talk about his inflinching
politeness
when he when when you would talk with
him and yet all cnn can boil that down
to
is he's a bad person right that's what
cnn is boiling it down to
and you get the same thing from the new
york times so the new york times ran
this headline this is the headline that
is currently up at the new york times
website quote
rush limbaugh who built talk radio into
right-wing attack machine dies
mr limbaugh 70 who helped transform the
gop pushed talk radio to the right with
misogynistic and racist language and
conspiracy theories
that is the most dismissive disgusting
and ridiculous headline
that i have read in quite a while from
the new york times that's saying a lot
they do this kind of crap regularly rush
limbaugh's legacy
to millions of americans is that he
taught them about conservatism
his legacy to millions of americans is
that he was entertaining about politics
and introduced them to politics his
legacy
to millions of americans is that he gave
them a way to fight back and the new
york times boils that down to he's a
racist misogynist
that's what they boil it down to by the
way i should just note some of the other
new york times
obituaries that they've run for public
figures this was run just a few years
ago
mao zedong died on this year in 1976 the
times said he began as an obscure
peasant and died one of history's
greatest revolutionary figures
or maybe fidel castro here is their obit
when fidel castro you know the brutal
and repressive cuban dictator
died here was there here was their
headline fidel castro cuban
revolutionary who defied u.s
dies at 90. how about ayatollah khomeini
you know
the radical anti-semitic genocidal
anti-jew
dictator of iran ayatollah khomeini 89
the unwavering iranian spiritual leader
or how about this for hugo chavez the
venezuelan dictator a polarizing figure
who led a movement
how about yahshua arafat you know one of
the founders of islamic terrorism
yasser arafat father and leader of
palestinian nationalism dies at 75.
so just to get this straight of all the
people i just mentioned
mao castro khomeini chavez
yasser arafat it's rush limbaugh who
deserves the most rage from the new york
times
why because rush threatened their
monopoly that's really what this is
about in the end
and so the blue checks were celebrating
last night because that's what they do
because
it is amazing that the people who
consider themselves the most virtuous
are the ones who are crapping all over a
man on the day he dies
see charlotte climber of course tweeting
out rush limbaugh was a coward and white
supremacist white supremacist
he aggressively and cynically exploited
divisions in our country by weaponizing
hatred and bigotry for his own personal
gain
he was in service to his own greed
prejudice and hypocrisy and that is how
history will remember him
just delightful delightful these folks
siobhan thompson r.i.p rush limbaugh
died 69 years later than he should have
beautiful stuff here from the left don't
worry it's rush who is the polarizing
figure you see
these people are all for unity the
excremental chang iger
says uyghur says the idea that you say
artificially nice things about people
after they die is weird
i've never understood the logic of it
rush limbaugh was a terrible person
while he was alive he made a living by
attacking the powerless his death does
not in any way change
or redeem that says chenk wieger
he spends his days abusing travel staff
at the airlines
okay this stuff is just i'm sorry it's
just it's just gross there's no reason
to even dwell on it because all it does
is give attention to people who are
desperately seeking it
but the point is broader and that is the
reason that the left
hated rush is because rush was
representative of the fact that there is
dissent
because russia did not back down because
russia spoke clearly let's be perfectly
obvious about this
the reason they hate rush is the same
reason they hate everybody who does not
agree with them
because i promise you the reaction to
rush limbaugh's death it will be the
exact same reaction
if god forbid something would happen to
sean hannity or something would happen
to tucker carlson or something would
happen to megan kelly
or something would happen to glenn beck
or something would happen to dennis
prager or something would happen to mark
levin
or something would happen to me the
reaction would be exactly the same
exactly the same it would just be a
compendium of the quote-unquote worst
things that we'd ever said
and then it would be what a terrible
person we're glad they're dead
and the reason they feel that way is
because rush challenged the monopoly
rush changed the paradigm the left
doesn't like that the paradigm changed
the left doesn't decry polarization
because they hate polarization in and of
itself
if they did maybe they'd want to have
discussions with people on the right
occasionally
as opposed to trying to silence them no
the rush
believes that russia was polarizing the
left believes that russia was polarizing
because the left does not like the idea
that there even is descent the left does
not want there to be another side of the
aisle
everybody knows that they would treat
any person on the right who is not
serving as their
as their unique tool at a particular
time this way if john mccain had passed
away in 2008 while running against
barack obama you heard the exact same
crap about john mccain
if mitt romney had passed away in 2012
while running against barack obama you
have heard exactly the same thing
because john mccain died after having
sided with democrats on healthcare
and after having gone up against trump
then he was a hero same thing with mitt
romney right now
all that matters for the left is whether
you're a tool for them if you are not
you are an enemy
russia was an enemy and therefore he was
to be destroyed but he refused to be
destroyed
and in that lies a bit of inspiration
for all of us i would hope
okay in just a second we're going to get
to joe biden and his absolutely
incoherent covered strategy because it
is incoherence at this point
perfectly perfectly obviously incoherent
first let us talk about a way that
people can
steal your assets so what is your most
valuable asset well clearly your home
title right your home title is the most
valuable asset now nobody is actually
going to be able to go over with a truck
and pick up your home and drive away
with it because it's very very very
heavy but what they can do is they can
hack into
your home title you never thought that
covert could cost you your home but it
could because cyber crime is up by 75
by far the most serious cyber crime to
worry about is home title theft that is
correct
cyber criminals foreign and domestic are
now after our homes it is easier than
you'd think the title documents to our
homes are online now
the thief finds your home title and then
forges your signature on a quit claim
deed stating you sold your home to him
and then takes out loans on your home
and leaves you in debt you're not going
to know until late payment or eviction
notices arrive
insurance doesn't cover you neither do
common identity theft programs
that's why i protect my home with home
title lock
the instant home title lock detects
someone tampering with my home title
they help shut it down cold go to home
title lock dot com
register your address to see if you are
already a victim and then just use code
radio to receive 30 free days of
protection that is code radio at home
hometitlelock.com
once more that is home title lock.com
but quick note final note here on the on
the opposition to rush
what really is happening here is this is
part and parcel of a broader leftist
attempt to re-establish the monopoly
they had in the 70s 80s 60s
right the idea here from the left is
that the media monopoly must be
re-established at all costs it's the
reasons you are seeing them coming after
twitter and facebook and trying to
cuddle all of your social media sites
into down playing news dissemination it
is the reason they are attacking free
speech itself there's a piece in the new
york times today from thomas edsel
whose data analysis is usually pretty
good but he has an entire piece
about why democracy is weakening and
what is his theory about why democracy
is weakening it's because of digital
technology
because the fact is that the freedom of
the digital space is allowing people to
speak who should not be allowed to speak
this is a widespread view on the left
that freedom is itself a threat to
freedom
nathaniel personally a law professor at
stanford summarized the dilemma
in his 2019 report the internet's
challenge to democracy framing the
problem and assessing reforms
personally says the promise of the
internet has been replaced by concern
that the most democratic features of the
internet are in fact
endangering democracy itself democracies
pay a price for internet freedom
under this view in the form of
discrimination disinformation hate
speech incitement
and foreign interference in elections
writing separately in an email
personally argued twitter and facebook
allowed trump both to get around their
legacy intermediaries and to manipulate
them by setting their agenda they also
provided environments such as facebook
groups that have proven conducive to
radicalization and mobilization
margaret roberts political scientist at
uc san diego puts it differently quote
the difficult part about social media is
that the freedom of information online
can be weaponized to undermine democracy
okay this is the push the left has been
making they're making it since rush
limbaugh first came on the scene we need
our monopoly back otherwise it's going
to destroy democracy
if you need your informational monopoly
back or it's going to destroy democracy
i do not think you know what the word
democracy means
i certainly don't think you know what
freedom of speech means if your great
concern is that freedom of speech might
allow people who disagree with you to
speak
but that is really the agenda here okay
meanwhile
joe biden's joe biden's agenda president
biden's agenda
continues to be run by the radical left
he met in the oval office yesterday with
labor leaders to discuss coveted relief
and infrastructure reform
because obviously the people who should
be driving the bus when it comes to
coveted relief
are giant unions that contribute
enormous quantities of capital
to democratic campaigns by the way the
most corrupt thing that openly happens
in american politics
is that big labor funnels a bunch of
money to democratic candidates
particularly public sector unions
because then they just negotiate with
the people they elected
right this is the way the public sector
unions work the teachers unions for
example
teachers unions funnel money to people
like chicago mayor lori lightfoot
and then they strike and then they go to
lori lightfoot who they just elected and
they say
why don't we negotiate for better
benefits and more taxpayer dollars
and chicago mayor lori life was like
sounds great
it's the most corrupt open bargain in
american society and yet it is
considered perfectly fine
by folks on the left even though it is
people bargaining against the taxpayer
with people that they have essentially
gotten elected in the first place it's
really amazing so joe biden's agenda
is being run by the teachers unions when
it comes to kovid for example
and he's meeting with union leaders to
discuss all of his other jobs
programs despite the fact that private
sector unionization in the united states
is at an all-time low
when it comes to covert policy we were
told that joe biden was going to have
just the spectacular covered policy
right he was going to come into office
it was going to be
all hunky-dory right he wasn't he was
going to he wasn't going to
end the economy or hurt the economy he
was going to end the virus that's what
he was going to do
well here's the problem number one joe
biden is not with it i know that this is
supposed to be in politics to say
anyone with a functioning prefrontal
prefrontal cortex can see this
anyone this is not the guy he was even
30 years ago and he wasn't much to speak
about 30 years ago
i mean it's amazing to me the stuff that
joe biden is able to get away with just
because he's a democrat
so for example he had the cnn town hall
the other night and he literally said
that minorities don't know how to go
online
i mean can you imagine if a republican
said that if a conservative said
people who are black and hispanic don't
know how to go online the blowback would
be immediate and intense joe biden says
it and we're all just like oh grandpa
you're so silly sometimes and then we
shuttle him to the back
feed him some cream of wheat while he
plays mario kart here's president biden
a lot of people don't know how to
register not everybody in the community
in the hispanic and the african-american
community particularly in
rural areas that are distant and or
inner city
districts know how to use know how to
get online
to determine how to get in line for that
covert vaccination at the at the
walgreens
i mean joe biden is literally saying
that black and hispanic people are too
stupid to use the internet to find how
to get in line at walgreens
i'm pretty sure that's not true you know
how i know it's not true because it's
not true and kind of racist
joe but apparently that's totally fine
now we would be remiss
if we suggested that the failure of the
covid plans particularly when it comes
to school reopening from biden is
because of his
appearance incipient senility right that
would be remiss
okay it is not really because of joe
biden personally
it's really because he has no plan it's
because he is in hawks of the teachers
unions the science disagrees with the
teachers unions
and when political interest and science
come into conflict the party of
science tells the science to take a hike
this is why kamala harris
right who is not suffering from the same
effects of old age
as joe biden stammered her way through
an interview
about what coveted school reopening
policy should look like i don't think
that joe biden's inarticulateness is
infectious
i think that kamala harris has no good
answer to this question because the
administration has no good answer to
this question because the answer is
perfectly obvious which is that they are
serving
the interests of the teachers unions and
screwing the students over so kamala
harris has asked straight up
about the biden school reopening plan
and listen to this lady i mean she
she has no clue what to say because it
is against her political interest to say
the truth which is that schools need to
reopen
now we are
the the issue here is not just about
statistics it's about our kids
it's about their parents it's about the
fact that every day our kids are missing
essential
critical days in their educational
development you know
we we know we have worked on this issue
for years around
the fact that you know by the end of
third grade if a child is not at third
grade reading level
they literally drop off so each day in
the life of a child is a
very long time the question was how are
you going to reopen schools
that was the question and she can't get
through an answer instead she has to
just go to
schools are good yeah we know that's why
we want them reopened
and we're going to get to the complete
incoherence of this policy in just one
second because it is completely
incoherent you are hearing a different
message
from different members of the
administration every 30 seconds they all
conflict with each other and there is no
unifying principle other than
we can't give you a straight answer
because the teachers unions haven't told
us what to say yet
okay we're gonna get to more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that sometimes it is really
hard to find the proper person to fill
the role at your business and right now
i think the economy is going to start
going great guns as the vaccines that
kick in
as we start ignoring the silliness of
our politicians and
i think that'll be great i think that
people are going to go shopping again i
think that people are going to
start using services again the jobs
market is going to tick up is what
pretty much all of financial forecasts
say it's time for your business to grow
but you need the best employees and if
you're an employee
you need the best employer where can you
hook up here ziprecruiter.com
if you're in charge of hiring for your
business these pivots have made your job
even more challenging you know
the pivots of the coveted pandemic and
the down economy but
zip recruiter can fix this for you
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on
ziprecruiter it gets sent out to over
100 top job boards with one click
then zip recruiter's powerful technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites these people to
apply it's no wonder that four out of
five employers who post unzipper crew
get a quality candidate within
the very first day see for yourself
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire that is
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-zip recruiter.com
dailywire let zip recruiter take hiring
off your plate so you can focus on
growing your business head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruit is indeed the
smartest way to hire
alrighty before we go any further let me
remind you last friday the daily wire
announced a movie deal with gina carano
the former actress on the mandalorian
she was cancelled of course because she
is conservative
so we here at the daily wire have
decided to team up with gina within
hours of us making the announcement the
news went absolutely viral from usa
today to the la times so variety
shock or outrage there was still a
massive show of coverage headline after
headlines documented
gina's rejection of cancelled culture is
a brave move by gina
because that's exactly what this was it
was more than a statement it was a first
move to fight back against the
totalitarian mob
and uncancel people who shouldn't have
been canceled in the first place in
gina's own words they cannot cancel us
if we don't let them
and we won't that is why daily wire has
entered the entertainment space that's
why we want you to be part of this fight
to reclaim our culture head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe use cogina to get 25 off your
membership today that's it g
i n a to get 25 off we are stoked
for all of the entertainment content
ahead we are making it right now we want
you to be a part of it it's expensive
stuff we need your help
go to dailywire.com subscribe use code
gina also next week we are having a
state of the union
backstage so we will suffer through joe
biden mushmouthing his way
through the state of the union address
if you wish to suffer with us
or simply to gaze in horror as we all
suffer together
well then head on over to dailywire.com
and become a subscriber you can get all
of the privileges of being an all-access
member
right now when you use codegenie get 25
off go check us out right now you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so the biden administration they have no
clue what to say on the school stuff
because
the science conflicts with what they
actually want so we get 10 different
positions on this from the same
administration so first of all i'm
getting real sick of hearing from the
biden administration that we have no
idea when everybody will feel normal
again the answer is
when vaccination is widespread end of
story okay because guess what
when when vaccination is widespread i'm
going back to my regular life and i
think you are too
because vaccination is cutting down on
transmission in radical ways it is
cutting down
on serious sickness in radical ways and
once you've been vaccinated there ain't
much more you can do
okay i'm not going to live in terror of
a virus that already had a low death
rate for people in my age range
compared to certainly people above the
age of 70. and then after i get a
vaccine which reduces
the risk of that virus by 95 then i'm
going to still sit in my house and never
go to a ball game again forget it not
gonna happen
okay but according to the binding
administration we have to do this
forever they have no pathway out of this
because they kind of like it it is
perfectly obvious at this point
that the folks who are in charge of the
of the democratic party
are kind to fine and they're kind of
fond of the amount of control they've
been able to leverage and exert over the
course of this past year and they are
not going to let it go anytime soon here
is jen
we are not in a place where we can
predict exactly when everybody will feel
normal again and it has
there are a number of reasons one is
even though we will have
enough doses for every person in this
country as you all know because we've
talked about it in here
vaccine hesitancy remains a challenge
we need to ensure that that everybody
who
can get a dose is getting a dose uh we
all will also need to be masking for
some time
we also need to be still taking social
distancing measures so uh
you know there there's of course is an
understandable question and i think
the president uh wants things to return
to normal as we all do
uh but we uh we we don't know at this
point what that timeline is going to
look like but forget about the timeline
you haven't even set the standards for
when we can return to normal
forget about like giving us an exact
date tell me when
the number of vaccinations handed out
allows me to go to a ballgame
again i mean that seems like that should
be something science should be able to
tell us
no but apparently not because it's more
important to simply kick the can down
the road by the way if you want to
disincentivize people from getting the
vaccine
at a time when a huge number of
americans are already declining to get
the vaccine
continue to do this crap where you say
that things are never going to go back
to normal after you've had the vaccine
why in the world would a 20 year old go
get the vaccine if you're telling them
that even after they have the vaccine
they have to socially distance and wear
a mask and they're going to mask shame
them
if they don't wear a mask after they've
had the vaccine absolutely asinine
ridiculous crap here from the biden
administration but that's not the worst
of it
listen to the various views of the biden
administration on
getting back to schooling okay so here's
jen saki explaining that joe biden
doesn't think that teachers need to be
vaccinated to go back to school
does the president believe that teachers
need to be vaccinated
uh before they go back to school uh
no neither the president nor the vice
president believe
that um that it should be it is a
requirement
uh this the cdc guidelines included
a range of mitigation steps including
vaccinations as recommendations but the
mitigation steps also
included uh steps like social distancing
if that sounds like she's not setting
any standards because she's not okay so
why don't we just head on over to the
vp's office and she mentioned the vp
right there you know the vice
presidential spokeswoman simone sanders
she was on cnn and she was asked
directly
whether biden thinks the schools can
open even after
or if the teachers are not vaccinated
and here are simone sanders just dodging
the question
the president vice president believed
that teachers should be prioritized
for receiving the vaccination along with
other frontline workers
is it necessary though that's the
question it really is a yes no question
well john i think the real question
frankly if i can be frank here is
what you're getting to is is it safe for
kids to go
back to school and the president is
actually not in this case that's not the
question the question is is it safe for
teachers to go back to school
it is the administration's position the
president and vice president believe
the teachers should be prioritized for
vaccinations and in 22 states
at least and the district of columbia
that's exactly what is happening
you know uh look i'll try one last time
i'll try it last time
does the president does the president
feel that
that teachers have to be vaccinated in
order for schools to
open safely yes or no the president
believes that teachers should be
prioritized for vaccination his
wife okay credit where credit is due to
john berman of cnn he's just getting
more and more exasperated throughout
this interview being like this is a
very easy question can we open the
schools even if the teachers aren't
vaccinated and she's like
i like vaccines like that's not what are
you talking about right now i don't
understand i asked you a simple question
can kids go back to school if the
teachers are not fully vaccinated and
she's like i also like the movie toy
story
he's like what are you talking about
right now i don't know what you're
saying
okay this administration has no coherent
through line it's amazing it's amazing
for a year they yelled at trump for not
having a coherent through line and there
was truth to that
but then they get in office and they're
even more discombobulated than trump
ever was i mean it's unreal
it's unreal and you know who's
contributing to the sense of
discombobulation
the greatest doctor of all time outside
of dr joe biden dr anthony fauci the
world's greatest most important
doctor in human history it goes again
hippocrates
dr j dr fauci dr joe biden i mean this
dude is so
the doctoring the the level of doctoring
exhibited by
anthony thatcher over the course of the
last month alone should win him
just a straight ticket to dr heaven it's
incredible stuff
he's just amazing amazing here so here's
dr fauci
being asked about you know teachers and
their level of risk and somebody asked a
pretty simple question which is
um so how many teachers have died i've
covered in the united states by being
infected at schools
now to my knowledge the answer currently
proven
is zero seriously
i've had people send me articles
recently a producer jessica she sent her
an article
in which it said a teacher had died
after being in school
and then you read the article and in
paragraph 20 of the article it says the
teacher's family said it could not be
ascertained as to whether she actually
got coveted at school
there were articles during the summer
when school wasn't in session about
teachers dying and they were like
teachers are dying well if you get
infected not in school
then how the hell are you blaming the
schools anyway so dr fauci
he says that the the task force the cdc
task force
is not even tracking teacher deaths now
if you wanted to determine whether it's
safe for teachers to go back to school
wouldn't that be kind of an important
stat how many teachers are dying of
covet after being infected in school in
fact wouldn't that be the only stat that
matters but don't worry we're not
tracking it
and we can count on these crappy cdc
guidelines that were done
with the input of the teachers unions
according to the cdc's own head rachelle
bolensky here is dr fauci being just
unbelievable doctoring right here
i have not seen it broken down on number
of teachers who have
died i don't think that information is
readily available
we do say and we feel strongly that we
should try as best as we possibly can
to vaccinate teachers and they should be
as a high priority
within the area of essential personnel
come on come on so i don't have any data
on that and um we don't need data on
that because the science says we should
follow these crappy guidelines that i
made with
the american federation of teachers well
done by the way it's all not political
right
it's super not political in fact it's so
not political that biden's kovidzar got
him jeff zides
he came out yesterday and he said you
know what the only way we can reopen
schools is if we get another 130 billion
dollars from the coveted package
okay there's only one problem we have
hundreds of millions of unspent dollars
for schools the schools aren't open
right now
the hell are you talking about the hell
are you saying
also that 1.9 trillion plan has
billions of dollars earmarked not for
2021 not for 2022 for schools for 2023
and 2024
if you think that we're still going to
be spending like this in 2023 2024 on
schools to reopen them
then honestly if the right can't take
advantage of this by getting everybody
into private school like asap they are
making a
grave error now would be the best time
for a homeschooling and private
schooling movement in human history
here is jeff science following the
science by saying things that are
completely
you know irrelevant to the science doing
this
smaller class sizes ensuring they're
more school buses
having the equipment and the testing
available
this costs money and that's why the
passage of the american rescue plan the
130 billion dollars for schools is so
important to do uh it's
so much more expensive than the 130
billion dollars to not have
our kids in school uh in any setting
that is safe
uh and and feasible in this environment
more money that's that's the answer more
money okay but then when the more money
comes what if the kids what if the
teachers aren't vaccinated
well then we'll you know we like
vaccines and toy story
so i guess it's all good this is the
pros we were told by the media the pros
are in man the amateurs are gone the
pros are back
there's only one problem the pros suck
at this they suck at this how bad do
they suck at this they have
no good answers to anything they're
getting owned by the liberals over on
msnbc about their lack of a coveted
policy when msnbc is looking cross-eyed
at the biden administration for their
lack of a covert policy
you know things are kind of bad here's
msnbc stephanie i mean they're getting
owned by anchors at cnn and msnbc that's
how bad this is for the democrats
stephanie rule and msnbc
confronted a biden spokesperson and
asked a very simple question
it's weird you guys keep pushing
lockdown but it seems to me like
california is in lockdown and florida is
not
and their death per million stats are
very very similar and florida is the
second oldest state in america and
california is the fifth youngest state
in america
so what gives contrast states like
florida and california
um california basically in lockdown and
their numbers aren't that different from
florida
well good morning stephanie uh look
there's so much of this
virus that we think we understand that
we think we can predict
that's just beyond a little bit beyond
our explanation what we do know
is that the more careful people are the
more they mask and social distance
and the quicker we vaccinate the quicker
it goes away and the less it spreads
okay andy salev just completely ignored
the question he just ignored the
question completely
she's like florida's wide open
california is completely closed their
numbers are the same he's like there's
one thing that we know about this virus
and that that's california's right
so what what in the world the entire
premise of the question
is that california and florida are doing
polar opposite things and ending up with
the same numbers and florida's a way
older state and he's like
here's the thing we don't know anything
we're incredibly stupid and ignorant
but there is one thing we know and that
is that we are right
okay guys you sound like you you're in
control i believe you
i think i believe you and i especially
believe democrats because
they do things like get the kudos of the
media they are treated as the greatest
of all time and handling things like
pandemics
and then they bully the living crap out
of people who descend
andrew cuomo i'm speaking your language
right now according to the daily wire
ryan sivedra
a democrat new york state assemblyman
claimed on wednesday the new york
governor andrew cuomo the greatest of
all governors guys
threatened to destroy him after the
lawmaker criticized cuomo's handling of
the coronavirus pandemic
as it related to the state's nursing
homes assemblyman ron kim told cnn
cuomo called him last thursday to quote
threaten my career if i did not cover up
for melissa de rosa and what she said
he tried to pressure me to issue a
statement it was a very traumatizing
experience
apparently cuomo also allegedly told him
quote we're in this business together
we don't cross certain lines and he said
i hadn't seen his wrath and then he can
destroy me
they're all it's amazing trump was a bad
guy for saying stuff like this all the
time
democrats say this kind of crap all the
time andrew cuomo is a bully
he is a thug everybody in politics has
known this in new york
for years even bill de blasio thinks
that andrew cuomo is garbage i mean like
it's it's unbelievable and they treated
this guy as like the king of kovid
anthony thatcher was like that governor
is amazing and then anthony fatchi's
asked about the fact that he's covering
up data and anthony fought like well i
won't comment on that i can't comment on
that
oh really weird because you were
commenting on it five seconds ago
if i sound a little upset it's because
these governmental experts who proclaim
that you should give them more power
do not know their ass from their elbow
they don't know anything
and then when you dissent then they say
things like oh you're a kova denier
this is it's all about quashing the
ability of people to speak freely
it is all about denying the science in
many cases and it is all about false
narratives
they joe biden was elected really for
one reason and one reason only and that
is the american people thought that
donald trump botched coveted
if you look at the polls that is the
real reason that donald trump lost the
election beyond all of the other
crazinesses and beyond all the
personality foibles and all of that if
covet doesn't arise
biden doesn't get elected okay it's
pretty simple
but they he was elected on the promise
he was going to know what he's doing and
they don't know what they're doing and
the media
are now now that the election's over now
they can actually ask these questions
remember some of us were asking these
questions
during the campaign is this guy in favor
of lockdown how will he open schools
what exactly is his plan
and the media were like you're asking
about his plan trump's the president
it's like right but he wants to
be the president you should probably ask
him about you know his plans
and you're like no no no no cuomo is
amazing we're not going to ask about his
plans don't be so
and then he gets elected it's like so
your plan and mine's like trump
relationship
and they're like well that doesn't make
any sense right and it didn't make any
sense in november either
it didn't make any sense in october or
september but you guys were too busy
drooling all over the guy
unreal okay meanwhile speaking of our
mainstream media botching the science it
is amusing to watch the media attempt to
cover for wind power
okay so here's the thing if there is one
thing that we should have learned from
what just happened in texas
there are a few things one you got to
harden your electrical grid you got to
make sure that you
have the warming capacity necessary you
got to build more nuclear power plants
if there's one thing that we know for
sure though is that more windmills would
not have helped
more windmills would have been a very
bad idea in texas in fact here is a
chart
this is from alex epstein alex epstein
put out this chart about solar energy
and wind energy and how they performed
in texas
in the middle of this of this freeze
alex is the co-founder of
thoughtful.community and he's author of
the moral case for fossil fuels
here is what the texas electrical grid
looked like the red line
is the amount of demand for electricity
the blue in this chart is the amount of
wind generated power
the yellow is the amount of solar
generated power
you will see on february 4th there's a
fair amount of wind and solar generated
power
and then as the storm hit look what
happened why it's almost is the wind and
solar generation
completely failed they were unreliable
sources of energy here's the thing
you can do gas production in the middle
of freezing temperatures it happens in
alaska and norway all the time as the
media is fond of pointing out
you can do nuclear one thing you cannot
do wind generation or solar generation
at least not in huge numbers and yet the
media's takeaway is that solar is
necessary we need more solar and more
wind if your takeaway
from freezing temperatures leading to an
energy shortage in texas is that we need
more of the thing that failed the most
during this thing
you're completely insane it's nuts and
yet these are our
amazing journalism experts they are
saying that what this means is that we
need a green new deal
i mean it's amazing like when things are
good for oil and gas
we need a green new deal because we
don't want people using oil and gas then
when things are bad for oil and gas we
need a green new deal almost as though
all you give a crap about
is building alternative sources of
energy that are significantly
significantly too expensive epstein has
a threat about this
he says there's a lot of conflicting
information about the texas blackouts
here's the bottom line
the root cause of the texas blackouts is
a national and state policy that has
prioritized the adoption of unreliable
wind and solar energy over reliable
energy
for the last decade plus policy in texas
and the united states has been focused
on mandating or subsidizing as
subsidizing
as much wind and solar as possible texas
has bragged about being the biggest wind
generator in the united states
the texas focus on wind has come above
all at the expense of coal which has the
resiliency advantage along with nuclear
being able to store large quantities of
fuel on site
gas mostly requires just-in-time
delivery from pipelines
but they stop developing coal and they
stop developing nuclear and they spend
all of the money on wind and solar
and that is why you end up with energy
shortages in places like texas right now
texas plans include
zero new nuclear plants zero new coal
plants 9.4 gigawatts
of wind 11.9 gigawatts of solar
and only five gigawatts of gas
those are bad plans the media by
contrast they're like you know what
aoc let's let's talk to aoc about this
here's brianna keeler from cnn
saying that aoc's green new deal is the
solution to this which is the dumbest
thing
that anyone has said about this crisis
thus far it's all the windmill's fault
governor greg abbott says not missing
the chance to spin a yarn for political
gain in the middle of a crisis
he blames renewable energy for the
rolling power outages that have texans
seeking refuge in their cars as the
temperatures in their homes
drop into the 40s but he's wrong experts
say that it is a
garden variety of reasons congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez one of the
architects of the climate legislation
responded
quote the infrastructure failures in
texas are quite literally what happens
when you don't pursue a green new deal
well i mean if the former waitress says
so i guess that we're done here
i mean if the bartender who has a degree
in economics from boston university
and yet somehow thinks that the solution
to this is more windmills
says so i guess we should probably
should listen to her if somebody if
somebody knows energy policy it's the
lady who thinks
that we should build high-speed rail get
rid of planes and retrofit every
building in the united states
and also stop eating meat probably she
is the obviously she's the expert
i'm so glad that brianna killer of cnn
could really put her finger
on the pulse of the nation texas freezes
go to aoc
at her bistro in brooklyn okay meanwhile
the media are going nuts today
because ted cruz apparently is in cancun
now i will admit that this is bad optics
of course it's bad optics whenever
there's a crisis if you are seen to be
having
any sort of good time because our
politics are incredibly stupid this
means that you're responsible for the
crisis
everything in politics is performative
right now members of congress don't do
anything for a living all they do is
gather once every so often to spend too
much of your money
and so everything becomes performative
right the reason that aoc is a star is
because
she goes to immigration facilities and
takes
photo shoots outside immigration
facilities being emotional in response
to what is going on
apparently inside the immigration
facilities oh yeah i mean
the more performative you are in
politics the better you do these days
that is just the reality of the
situation so i get that it's bad optics
for
ted cruz to take his family on vacation
to cancun right now it even sounds bad
but let's be real about this for just
one second this is one of the stupidest
aspects of our politics
like what exactly it's not a real-time
crisis that ted cruz the senator from
texas can do anything
about because the senator from texas is
in fact in the united states senate he's
a federal officer
right he's a federal elected official
this is up to the mayor
of houston and like the governor of
texas
and all the people who are level
officials and also
i just wonder what is ted cruz like did
they expect ted to go there with like a
blow torch and start
defrosting all of the pipelines he can
do what beta or work does and he can
tweet out a bunch of links to people who
are helping out
i'm sure ted's already done that but the
the the notion that
the gravest of all sins is that you took
your family to a place that is not texas
in the middle of a bad situation in
texas
my favorite part of this is all the
journalists in their heated apartments
in new york who are tweeting angrily
about all of this i can't believe ted
cruz would do something like this oh
yeah
i see you there on the ground handing
out food really
well done there really really well done
okay meanwhile
i'd be remiss if i did not get to what
is easily the stupidest story of the day
this is the stupidest story of the day
this is from the wellness section at the
washington post so
you may recall that there is a woman who
is stupid enough to put a bunch of
gorilla glue in her hair
this is very stupid gorilla glue is glue
as indicated by the name gorilla glue
right it is super glue essentially why
would you put that in your hair
unless you're a dum-dum okay the lady's
a dum-dum
as evidenced by the fact that she put
glue in her hair i don't even have to go
further than that you take gorilla glue
and you spray it in your hair
yay you ain't getting into phi beta
capita hey
how does the washington post spin this
well it turns out that the lady was
black
i had no idea but apparently she is
this means that the reason she sprayed
gorilla glue in her hair i'm not kidding
you
the reason she sprayed gorilla glue in
her hair is because of systemic racism
according to the washington post which
is weird because i have not seen
a massive spate of black people spraying
gorilla glue into their hair only this
dumb lady
like this is not a systemic problem in
the black community people spray
painting their hair with gorilla glue
like that's not a thing the reason this
lady was a headline is because she did
something unbelievably stupid
and then it went viral online and the
washington post was like yes but
have you considered the possibility that
this is an outgrowth of
400 years of oppression i know i didn't
consider that possibility because
oppressed people
generally don't spray gorilla glue in
their hair
weird but here is the washington post
armedia they don't have a narrative guys
they are perfectly objective remember
this is not in the op-ed section
leticia beach i'm writing jessica brown
no longer feels like she has red ants
crawling around her skull scalp
brown 40 nicknamed gorilla glue girl
captured the internet's attention with
her forever ponytail
after she used gorilla glue spray a very
strong adhesive for heavy duty project
to create possibly the slickest of side
parts and swooped edges
known to womankind the embarrassing
ordeal has left brown with some missing
baby hairs bald patches that are
expected to recover and a much shorter
hairstyle that's nowhere near the amount
of inches she had with her month-long
braid
over the next six weeks brown can't put
put much else on her scalp except for a
concoction
created by a beverly hills
california-based plastic surgeon who
removed the glue from her hair
at this point i'm scared to put a
relaxer on my hair she told the
washington post in an interview adding
she has decided to go natural
and embrace the naturalness of her hair
brown sawdust as the washington
post which first went viral on social
media and then became national news
appealed to some black people who still
shudder at the thought of a relaxer or
the sizzling pain of a hot comb that got
too close to skin
memories that have led many black women
to support their own kinks and curls
plenty of people ridiculed and got their
belly laughs at brown's misfortune but
there was a sense of community among
others
especially black people who sought to
shield her from being a spectacle of
idiocy
the extreme she went to for zero
flyaways is very unusual
but the desired outcome is as old as
black people's time in a country that
often mocked how they look
experts say
what now huh
so you want to talk about the history of
people discriminating on the basis of
race
and you want to talk about the the
discriminatory attitude towards
particular types of hair that have
existed in american society perfectly
fine
if you want to say that this lady is
like a perfect example
of discrimination on the basis of hair
because she used gorilla glue in her
hair
again can't we just say that some people
are idiots and do stupid things is that
possible can we do that
is that ever a possibility also
note to the world there are a lot of
very prominent black americans
who are not doing any of these things
anymore which is great people should be
able to wear their hair however they
feel like wearing their hair that's fine
why you would lump in people who want to
wear their hair a certain way
with gorilla glue lady or suggest that
american society is to blame for a dummy
putting gorilla glue on her head
is be i mean it's not beyond me i know
exactly why they're doing it right it's
every problem in american society is
attributable to systems of power those
systems of power
are rooted in innate white supremacy so
if a dumb lady puts gorilla glue on her
head and she happens to be a black lady
who put
glue on her head it has to be that this
is a legacy of america's hierarchies of
power coming all the way back to 1619.
think peace in the new york times
this one at least is in the washington
post the mother of five said she was
familiar with gorilla glue before her
very unfortunate mistake
often using it around her louisiana home
for tasks such as setting up christmas
decorations okay first of all
that right there would be a good
indicator that she has a complete
it's not as though she went to the store
and she's like oh it says gorilla glue
and it's a spray so maybe it's a hair
spray
she used it around her home to glue
things and then she put it in her hair
okay this is the equivalent of the lady
who gave fish tank cleaner to her
husband
because she thought that fish tank
cleaner was hydroxychloroquine
people doing dumb things are usually not
outgrowths of systemic racism they're
just people doing dumb things
when she ran out of her favorite got to
be glued hairspray she reached for the
gorilla spray adhesive to save on time
before leaving her home
she figured she could just spray it on
her hair and wash it out once she got
home that day i don't know why you'd
figure that unless you're a dummy unless
you're stupid
days turned into a week before she
shamefully admitted to her mother what
she had done
that week became a month before she went
to social media to seek help she said
i'm sorry the fact that she was like
sitting around for a month and she's
like i uh my hair is
glued like after two days you weren't
like this is kind of a problem
she said the only reason why i took it
to social media is because we ran out of
things to do
i figured somebody out there would be
able to tell me what to do i never
thought my little girl would say my your
video has a million views
shadow console one of her young
daughters who said she endured taunts
from other children making fun
of her mother don't make fun of kids i
mean it's not the kid's fault that mommy
is
is not particularly bright brown had to
keep under control the angst of possibly
never running her fingers through her
hair again for the sake of the children
who came to her daycare tessa's little
angels learning academy
neil lester said he initially thought
brown's problem was a prank but as he
continued to follow this story he said
it reminded him of all the ways black
americans have used unusual hair
products to manipulate or style their
hair
i thought of malcolm x and his
experience with the conch said
foundation professor of english and
founding director of project of
humanities at arizona's arizona state
university
referring to the hair straightener made
of lye eggs and potatoes used by many
black people in the earlier and middle
part of the 20th century
that stringing started with enslaved
people using axle wheel grease
and dirty dishwasher with oil enslaved
men used axle wheel greases and means to
dye their hair or temporarily straighten
it
women would use butter fat from bacon or
grease from geese to care for their hair
according to hair story
untangling the roots of black hair in
america
uh yeah that's it
well see
she's not enslaved she
was not attempting to according to her
abide by white standards of beauty or
anything she doesn't there's nothing in
here that says that that's what she was
attempting to do
she said she just liked her hair that
way but it's still systemic racism
so as always the root of every problem
in life is systemic american racism
the only solution hire impromex kendrick
for twenty thousand dollars to tell you
that you're a white supremacist
otherwise this sort of evil will run
rampant across society people gorilla
gluing their hair
every single day as a direct outgrowth
of the legacy of racism in the united
states
oh washington post i can't imagine why
people mistrust our institutional media
they're so good at what they do
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airing
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
on the matt walsh show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show